WATCHED THE STATE OF THE UNION
LAST NIGHT THAT MADE IT A
PERFECT TIME TO PUT
UNCOMFORTABLE NEWS IN THE MEDIA
BLOOD STREAM.
PERFECT TIME IN YOU'RE HILLARY
CLINTON BEFORE PRESIDENT TRUMP
STARTED TALKING LAST NIGHT
IT WAS 1500 WORDS LONG AND
SAVAGED ONLINE AND NOT WELL
RECEIVE AND CLINTON BOTCHES HER
MOMENT CLAIMS VANITY FAIR AND
KENNY BRUCE SAY NEW YORK RADIO
HOST AND JOINS US TO ASSESS THE
STATE OF HILLARY CLINTON IN THE
ME TOO MOVEMENT.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF HER
EXPLANATION LAST NIGHT?
>> IT SOUNDED TO ME LIKE LOOK,
SHE PROBABLY THOUGHT THIS WAS
HER STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS
AND BROKE INTO THE CHARDONNAY
CABINET AND THE REST IS HISTORY.
IT WAS WAY TOO LONG --
WANTING TO MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HER REALIZING SHE HAD BEEN
EXPOSED FOR BEING THE FRAUD SHE.
THIS IS THE IRONY ABOUT HILLARY
CLINTON.
AND THE NEVER APOLOGIZED FOR
SHIELDING THIS MAN AND
DISRUPTING THE WORK LIFE OF THIS
WOMAN WHO WAS THE TARGET.
HE WROTE IN PART, I DID IT
BECAUSE I DIDN'T THINK FIRING
HIM WAS THE RIGHT SOLUTION TO
THE PROBLEM AND NEEDED TO BE
PUNISHED AND CHANGE HIS BEHAVIOR
AND UNDERSTAND WHY HIS ACTIONS
WERE WRONG.
I THOUGHT THIS COULD HAPPEN
WITHOUT HIM LOSING HIS JOB.
TUCKER, SHE'S TALKING ABOUT HER
HUSBAND.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM WITH HILLARY
CLINTON.
TO REACT TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND PREDATORY SITUATIONS SHE HAS
TO ADMIT EVERYTHING SHE'S DONE
IN THE PAST HAS BEEN WRONG AND
SHE CAN'T DO IT.
AND HILARY -- AND I'M GLAD SOME
OF THESE WOMEN ARE REALIZING IT,
>> Tucker: WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
MOST PEOPLE WOULD GIVE HILARY A
PASS ON HER HUSBAND AS YOU DO IN
COMPLICATED PERSONAL SITUATION.
SHE SAID I WON'T WEIGH IN ON
THIS BECAUSE IT'S TO WEIRD.
I'M NOT GOING TO IMPOSE MY VIEWS
ON YOU.
INSTEAD SHE GOES OUT AND STARTS
WHY DOES SHE DO THAT?
>> LOOK, SHE DID GET INVOLVED IN
THE SMEARING OF THE WOMEN AND IN
THE CAMPAIGN SHE PRESENTED
HERSELF AS A WOMAN BECAUSE A
WOMAN WILL GOVERN DIFFERENTLY.
A WOMAN WILL NOT DO THE THINGS
MEN DO AND THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
UNTRUE.
MY POSITION AS A FEMINIST IS
WOMEN DO EVERYTHING MEN CAN DO
AND WE NEED TO BE IN MORE
POSITIONS OF POWER BUT THIS IS
AN ISSUE OF CHARACTER NOT OF
GENDER.
AND MAYBE HILLARY CLINTON WILL
DO SOMETHING THAT'S GOOD BY HER
HISTORY WHICH HAS PROVED TO US
HAVE POWER WE HAVE TO KEEP A